no no no hello Lieutenant man yeah yeah
yeah listen all right you're the
lieutenant yeah no no no right I'm
letting everyone in this room to call me
out on it
would you I don't think you do it though
George
I think you're too scared he is really
nice
use wonderment you've never said
anything even when I was like were you
in Mexico with us yeah turn this mic up
oh yeah use wonderment go why was the
Mexico who never didn't say anything
um but saying something down there
wouldn't have done any good no he why he
had strategy there because
uh when Andres tried to tell the the
waiter did not give you any alcohol in
your drink you started ordering ordering
doubles so you're very much it was
different and I understood like I
understand that when anybody tells you
not to do something I want to do it was
in the wild too as you're in Mexico
it was more of a
try to appease to a level that you won't
go even further yeah and the one thing I
did tell George was because I didn't
want you to go to Mexico I begged your
management to say hey you got to cancel
this he's really unwell he's just in a
full-blown [__] alcoholic binge but
all I told George was I don't care what
you do just bring him back alive and
then we'll talk about like an
intervention when you get home you
thought about being a drug counselor or
anything that kind of work
um no because I don't think I can relate
well because I've never had any
addictions or you you were nervous
better than most I can tell you you'd be
a great therapist yeah be real you'd be
great yeah yeah and that was scary that
you said that the night that he ran away
and uh we couldn't find him yeah it was
that was my voice just ringing I ran
away where
um into the jungle Bobby yeah thanks for
trying to walk you back to your room and
you noticed that we were trying to walk
you you were hiding I believe and you
were like oh then I'm going to go I I
got in a fight with that um Palestinian
guy in the oh God I need more
I just vaguely remember I was like no I
mean it's like why do you guys can't get
along with the Jews oh boy
why why you know what I mean and I
wasn't Jewish I would tell them let's
get together you know what I mean like I
was gonna try to negotiate the piece
right right there right but like that I
went off to do that oh well so sorry I
was trying to save the world let you go
sooner I was trying to save the world
all right but they did bring you back
alive yeah and then you did get sober
soon after we were driving you and I to
Korea Town and I looked at you and said
what's up it's time wait what's up I was
like is it time and you looked at me and
you said yeah I think I think it's time
yeah yeah and George if you use a lot
use don't don't ever come straight at
people use a lot of wonderment and
questions I'm wondering Bobby if you
ever thought about her oh that's a good
task it's called therapeutic wonderment
wonderment is the best from now from
here before that's that okay but from
here on out both of you guys you say
something I can't be there and and I've
been here
you've never said anything ever
pertaining to some other stuff I don't I
don't tell you don't do that I will look
at you and you make no eye contact with
me because you know I'm being serious
and you get uncomfortable when he gets
serious oh that's right
but you're the silly guy yeah and when
the silly guy gets serious it's weird
the one time I feel not being [__]
serious one time I feel like you
actually like really absorb what I was
saying yeah and it was interesting it
was what in the middle of your guys
break up the tension item was talking
between both of you separately and I was
here to fix something I was like all
right peace bro and you're like and you
just stood up from playing and crossed
your arm and started pacing started
asking me questions about your
relationship and I was like oh okay he
wants to talk so then I was just I was
not there to tell you what to do but it
was more was that sober than aren't
using you were Sober Sober yeah but it
was a very tense time yeah because I
care about what you think
and I respect you as a human being I
feel like we're friends yeah of course
and I you know so from now on if you see
your boss see something right the Korean
Elvis right
Almighty all right it's actor Rye
say something because it's the Adderall
talking but anyway
Siler whatever you're taking because you
know what are you taking
yeah and um there's some days like
yesterday I didn't take it at all
because I was sick and I just kind of
went I don't want to take it right but
that kind of concerns me